ふぅぅ…
ハワイに行きたい
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
皆さん、お家に『鍵』付いてますでしょうか
もう多分、逆に 鍵がない家の方が 少ないと 思うんですよ
で特に、なんか アパートとか
一人暮らしのお部屋だと、例えば外側ですよ家の外側だったら
鍵を挿して《ガチャ》っていって、開く
逆に家の 内側から だったら
なんかこう、つまみ みたいなやつを《カチッ》てやったら、開くまたは閉じる
ていうのが、まぁ一般的な形だと思うんですけども
そこで、わたくし……
................
(スッと手を置く)
思いついてしまった
外からも内側でも
開け閉めが出来るということは
これすなわち
無限の可能性があると僕は
踏んだわけでございます
というわけで今回は
ドアの鍵を開けても
ドアが永遠に開かないドッキリ
やっていこうと思います
まぁ やり方は いたって シンプルです
誰かが 外に出て、で帰って来ます
家の鍵が かかっているので(二"ヤ"ァ"ァ"ァ"ァ"ァ"ァ"ァ"ァ"ァ")
外側から 鍵を
こう 挿して、ドアの鍵を 開ける(フヘへへへへへへへ)
そして、開ける音と 同時タイミングで《ｶﾁｯ》
僕が、内側から 開けられた鍵を 瞬時に 掛けるんすよ  (プギャァァァァァァァｗｗｗｗｗ)
《ｶｼｶｼｯ》みたいな(ウェ？)
ｶﾞｼｯ《ガシャン》そして《ガシャン》
もうほぼ同じタイミング
要するに相手に悟られなければ
大丈夫だと思います
こうすることによって
外側から入ってきた人間は
鍵を開けたはずなのに鍵が閉まっている
そう錯覚してしまう
まさに…
永久のラビリンス
鍵を開けても開けても
一向に開かない『最強のドア』 が完成すると
思われます
というわけで早速やっていきましょう
ではいこう
《ｶﾁｯｶﾁ》
は)ようへい君すいません
先)はい
は)ちょっとお願いがあるんですけど
は)コンビニに行って
先)はい
は)コーラ 買ってきてもらっていいですか
先)1本でいいんすか
は)1本で大丈夫です
先)1本でいいんですよね
先)わかりました
は)行ってらっしゃい
先)はい
《ﾊﾞﾀﾝ》
(鍵を掛ける音)
ふむふむ…
ふむふむ(変顔)
はい、準備完了 です
さあ これで今 掛かせてる鍵は こっちなんで
彼が 帰って来て 彼は ここの 鍵を戻した 瞬間に
僕が すぐに、
《ｶﾁｬｯ》
戻す
彼は 何度 鍵を 開けても
開ける 動作が 閉める動作に 変わってしまう
追い詰められた時
彼は どうするんでしょうか
フゥ…
ハァァァ
(帰宅音)
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
(笑)
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
は)だぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ(悔)
は)ﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌ
先)へっへ(笑)？
ｗｗ
先)何？
(高笑い)
先)なんか 開かないなって 思って
は)実は、ドアを
は)開けても開けても
は)ドアが開かないドッキリだったんですけど
は)ちょっと 開けるペースが 早すぎて
先)ｗｗｗ
は)心が乱されてしまったｗ
だ)あぶねぇ
は)わぁ びっくりした
だ)危ない！危ない
は)何やってんすか
は)なんでﾀﾋにかk ﾀﾋににいった？
ｗｗｗｗ
は)なんでﾀﾋににいった？今
は)下の方から多分
だ)こっち？
は)うん
《ﾊﾞﾀﾝ》
やべ掛けてね～や
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
結局スピード勝負なんすよね
(帰宅音)
《ﾄﾞｺﾞﾝ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
《ﾄﾞｺﾞﾝ》
だ)あれ？
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
だ)え？
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
《ﾄﾞﾝｯﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝ》
だ)なんで？
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
《ｶﾞｯｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
《ﾄﾞｺﾞﾝ》
だ)ｗｗ
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
だ)ｗｗｗ
《ﾄﾞｺﾞﾝ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
だ)ｗｗもぉｗｗｗｗ
《ﾄﾞｺﾞ》
《ｶﾞﾁｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬｯ》
《ｶﾞﾁｬﾝ》
《ﾊﾞﾀｯ》
あぁぁはは
【暗転したED】
【いつものED】
ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝ♪
は)クソ《ﾄﾞﾝ》
だ)あぶねーｗ 何？
ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は)いや ドアを 開けても開けても 開かない扉ドッキリ
だ)うぅぅわｗｗうぜぇぇｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗ